[Music]
so my name's James Duke I'm in our
professional services group in Google
cloud specifically in our strategic
cloud engineering group I'm here with my
colleague shy I'm shy and I'm also part
of the professional services group also
aski strategic cloud engineer and we're
gonna talk to you today a little bit
about beginning the journey embarking
I'm sorry the journey towards container
izing your workloads so it's a little
bit a little few different pieces to
this talk so we just want to talk
through some of the things we're she
going to cover during this session so
the first thing we want to talk about is
what is a container what does it give
you and cut through some of the jargon
get to some of those buzzwords explain
what some of those are we'll cover a
little bit about the business benefits
and what does containerization get you
why would you do containerization we're
working what can you do that you
couldn't do before and a little bit
about a roadmap how do you get from
essentially no containerization to full
containerization and how would you start
at any point along that journey so we're
gonna come take you through those things
and we're going to we try and do a very
conversational here service which
hopefully should keep things interesting
um so why don't we start off with a
little bit about containers yep so yeah
so let's start with what is the big idea
behind containers why do we need them
and how do they help us so you may have
heard a lot of buzz words associated
with containers so what we're trying to
do here is make you understand why these
are associated with containers so we'll
revisit them once you've understood what
containers really are so this is this is
the sort of layman's definition of
containers so not not very technical but
technically correct still so containers
is about two capabilities the first
thing is the container technology allows
you to package your application and
everything that apply that that
application needs could be the
configuration any libraries that it
needs any runtimes like if you have Java
or Python and needs the runtime to run
the application
so packaging all that together into one
bundle and that bundle is
called an image so the first capability
is the ability to create that image and
then the second part is ability to run
that image as a process in an isolated
environment so isolated means that it's
sort of cut off from other processes
running on the same host and it it's the
resources it can use is limited it
cannot just run away with all the
resources so to to understand that a
little bit more let's look at the
history of of containers as well as you
know why how do applications typically
run on on a host so the operating system
is a key component running on on a
computer and it has a number of
components the core part of the OS is
called the kernel and that's the minimum
sort of software you need to to sort of
run on a computer and be able to use it
then you need additional you might need
system modules you might need utilities
tools that support your application or
help you manage that machine but the
kernel is the core that's the minimum
thing that you need so when the
application sort of run they are sharing
a lot of these resources they they might
be using shared libraries they can bring
their own but they might be sharing
libraries with other applications that
are running on the same host similarly
there they're time slicing the resources
the cpu and sharing the memory as well
and if one process runs away with the
memory it can starve the other processes
running on that machine so when when
you're sharing a host with regular
applications these are some of the
issues that can creep up the other thing
that can happen is that the shared
libraries different applications may
need different versions of those
libraries so if one application changes
the library that's installed it can
interfere with other applications so you
have things like hey this ran fine on my
machine or this runs fine in development
and you take it to test and it starts
failing and you know you can't figure
out what's going on so to get around
that you have a number of options
the first option is before we jump into
the virtualization piece I'm seeing it
I'm seeing the post-lunch coma happening
here so to see a little bit of audience
participation get some energy back into
the it's not really but the booth I
guess so who here has used a container
excellent who he has built a container
okay who's used a container
orchestration system like kubernetes or
yeah that's good number that's a good
number
who has moved an application from a vote
from like a VM environment to a
containerized environment okay good good
excellent so that's that's that tells me
one thing we're right at the sweet spot
here we can cover this theory about
containers name we're gonna spend the
majority of the time talking about the
journey towards getting there so
excellent and I'm already seeing more
smiles and energy Naru so that's good
stuff let's get stuck into
virtualization yeah so should I talk to
sit about the kind of the old school way
right where we have an operating system
and libraries and other kind of stuff
the next step on the journey is
virtualization so we're not quite at
full containers yet but we have the
ability to break up a physical machine a
physical host into a number of virtual
hosts which solves a number of those
problems right we now we have limits on
CPU and RAM usage we have isolation
between things but there's a lot of
overhead right because now as you see
here right for kernels for for VMs it
takes a long time to boot a kernel
kernel uses a lot of overhead a lot of
actual physical resources on the host
and so there is a limit to how much of
the actual usable computing power you
get out of a machine when you're using
virtualization so oh and they're also
slow to stop but you can see the buta
kernel booting the kernel takes too long
can take a long time so you want to spin
up a new VM there's a time component of
that which will reduce the speed at
which you can scale so it becomes a
limit on scaling so how do we solve that
problem well one approach is containers
and so container is another type of
virtualization essentially what we're
doing is we are we're sharing the kernel
so we're not dividing the actual hosts
into virtual machines we're just setting
up some boundaries around processes and
the word container we're containing each
process in its own sort of boundary
sandbox if you will and using the the
mechanism in the car in the kernel to
sort of limit the resources that each of
that process can take so it's sort of a
lightweight virtualization is the other
term that's used as well and whatever
you do inside the container stays there
and any changes that you make any
libraries that you bring into the
container do not impact any other
processes running on the host so let me
just show you guys a running container
I'll just do a brief demo so let me just
reconnect here it seems like I got
disconnected yeah so what I'm doing is I
have a Google Cloud VM which which can
run containers so I'm just logging in
there seemed like my session timed out
and what I'll do is I will run a
container and I'll show you how what
that container looks like from the point
of view of the container when you're
inside the container and how it looks
like for the other procede on the host
so let's just so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to use docker which is a you
know container runtime and run up an
image the nginx image that you guys
might be familiar with so what I'm doing
here is I am starting that that process
and what you will see is that that image
is now running so let's see what that
looks like from the point of view of the
of the hosts here so I'm going to look
at all the processes that are running on
this machine and what you'll see is that
there are other things running there but
there's this docker daemon and that is
running the docker runtime the container
runtime and you'll see that the nginx is
actually running in that process tree so
and and you can see all the other
processes that are there as well now
what I'll do is I'll just attach to that
container what you can do is you can you
can you can attach to a container and
essentially start a
come on inside the container so that's
what I'm doing I'm just attaching to
that and executing the bash shell so
what you'll see is my command prompt has
changed and now I'm in the context of
that container so any commands that I
run here are are running inside that
container so if I look at the file
system it has its own file system and if
I run that PS command in here what you
will see is you'll see a very limited
set of processes on the host you saw
that you you had all the other processes
that were running on the host but from
the containers point of view it sees
itself as the only process so it sees
the PS command that I ran the shell that
I'm in and the nginx which we actually
wanted to run so this shows you how the
processes are isolated from within the
container it cannot access any of the
other processes and you know it's sort
of isolated from those so that just
shows you you know what what a running
container actually looks like so just to
recap quickly the different ways of
running applications the traditional way
is shared hosts and we saw the problems
with that there's no isolation between
your applications things that one
application does can impact the other
applications if you have to prepare the
host to run the application your
libraries have to be a particular
version if they're not if you're you
know tools are not the right version you
might have issues then on the other end
we have the virtual machines which
provide a very high level of isolation
you can you can customize each virtual
machine to the exact sort of specs that
you need but the downside is that it's
expensive and inefficient and and you
virtual machines cannot be easily
resized you cannot increase the size of
a virtual machine that easily and and
it's generally a little bit harder to
manage but they do provide very high
isolation containers provide sort of a
middle ground where it does provide the
isolation you need you can you can you
know install whatever libraries you need
inside the container image and that way
your application will have exactly where
it needs
and only what it needs you don't want to
put a lot of extra stuff in there and
that way there's less overhead and you
can use the same host to to to run them
it to to host more than one application
so is the way the passwords always wrong
yes I had yeah so yeah so they provide a
good sort of middle ground where they
provide the isolation that you need but
they're nimble and lightweight so with
that we can revisit some of the
buzzwords and you'll hopefully
understand it a little bit better yes we
we promise at the beginning to cut
through the buzzwords we just used a
whole bunch of buzzwords in that
description so let's read let's revisit
them and really nailing down we talked a
lot about lightweight so containers are
lightweight you'll hear this a lot what
we're really talking about there is they
contain only what they need so we select
the VM we had all that extra stuff right
we had all the things that the operating
system needs the kernel the dependencies
libraries which likely are never used by
your application I can say MIT doesn't
have any of those things right it just
has the bare minimum you need to run
yeah and and that provides an extra
benefit that you don't have any tools
that if if someone you know to be
misused it reduces the attack surface so
if some you had some rogue process
running in your container it has less
tools at its disposal to to to sort of
wreak havoc in your VM and a very simple
ever it uses less resources which means
you can run more of them right you can
run more pros more containers on a given
physical host and you can run VM sort of
a given physical host yeah then also
portable you can move them around easily
yeah and yeah and we'll show you that
you once you've built your image you've
done the hard part and you can that
image is very portable since the image
contains everything you need all you
really need is a V is is sort of a host
to run it so you need compute and memory
and you can run it pretty much anywhere
and then you know we're gonna focus very
much on Google's platforms today but
that's true across all sorts of things
now you can pick up an engine movie to
another host another platform another
provider
it just has it has the ability to be
moved around
easily and partially because of the
lightweight they're fast right we don't
I said earlier overhead from a VM you
have to wait for the kernel to boot
which can take a long time
none of that with a container you start
a process that's how long it takes to
boot the container plus of course
anything that the container needs to do
for start-up of course but the actual
container itself runs much much much
faster than saying booting up a VM which
means when you're doing that portability
there's no cut there's no penalty in the
overhead of starting up that machine
right you don't have to wait two three
minutes whatever it might be to shutdown
and restart a VM it can be just like
that so you can scale up faster as well
since you can share the host you can run
multiple applications so your host a new
host Norton s does not necessarily have
to be spun up you can use the same host
and quickly start new processes to take
on additional load that's the buzzwords
yeah make sense
cut through do you feel sufficiently cut
through those buzzwords excellent good
stuff all right so let's see what what
it means for your business why do you
want to run containers now that you have
a basic understanding of what container
technology is so we see containers as
sort of an enabling technology it the
benefits will come after you've started
using containers it's sort of a price of
admission if you will or or you know
price you have to pay to be able to use
a lot of the other things and once
you've containerized you have a wide
variety of things available to you you
can go from you can deploy containers on
bare VMs what is also known as
infrastructure as a service or you can
move to a more managed service like
kubernetes engine which is typically
known as a platform as a service or you
can go to App Engine and server less
offerings that are now showing up in the
marketplace so it allows you to move
from one to the other
pretty much seamlessly and effortless
effortlessly I mean more or less what
we're saying here is all those things
that we just said a moment ago that is
what containers are those are the
business benefits right fast portable
lightweight they enable you to do more
things that you just could not do before
right so containerization in and of
itself isn't necessarily the end goal
and I've seen this
a lot with our customer right we have
people who want to come to us and say
well I need to containerized because
it's cool or I need to containerize
because all of my competitors are
container izing those are not great
motivations to do this because in and of
itself it doesn't give you anything
right you have if you took one
application and containerized it well
okay great it's now a containerized
version of the same thing it's what you
can do next
that was where the real business value
is and what it enables you to be able to
do and grow into yep so here just sticks
some examples of how you can take the
same image and run it on different sort
of products that Google Offers and and
these are completely sort of portable
between one and the other so you can
take the image just deploy it to compute
engine with a g-cloud command you can
use kubernetes cube control to deploy it
to a kubernetes engine cluster or you
can deploy the same image to an app
engine instance so that's that's three
different hosts three different targets
for the same image it's really that easy
three different commands and you've got
the same image running on three
different things so you have more
options so what do we do with those
options you know what are the different
choices of runtimes and what do they
mean for us right it's a it's a change
of problem before we had the problem of
how do we make the VM as good as
possible
now we have a question of where do we
put the container what how do we choose
the right home for that container to get
the maximum value the good news is if
you get it wrong it's that easy to
change they're different one
right two commands and you're back to
where you were so it's it's really very
low risk of a decision to make but it
does mean that we can use the different
advantages of the different platforms
for their actual business value rather
than just because it's what's
technically compatible with what we have
yeah and and the way to look at it is if
you look from left to right the the
options on the left end of the spectrum
give you more control but the downside
is they come with the overhead of you
managing your own infrastructure so you
have to manage your own VMs and and you
know it's sort of an overhead but that's
what a lot of organizations are used to
so it's a more familiar word world for
you so you can start there
start with compute engine and run you
know
containers on compute engine and then
you can you know graduate to two
different other offerings as you move
along or towards the right the the
offerings are more managed that means
that you have to spend less resources
managing those offerings and for for
smaller organization startups that's
typically they don't have the extra
resources to manage the infrastructure
so that's why we see a lot of startups
start on App Engine and it's it's geared
geared towards that and I'm sure you've
heard that a lot this week and prior
next and other Google events we're
forever talking about freeing up your
developers to do what's meaningful right
where the actual business impact is
keeping the lights running on a VM
probably doesn't make it your business
or your customers business money right
what makes the money is building new
innovation innovating new things
creating new opportunities for your
customers for their customers and so
freeing up your developers to do that is
great and this is a which I say here is
that by container izing we can get even
closer to that dream of minimizing the
amount of time and money that we spent
on these things which don't generate
that business value yeah and and the the
the sort of the trade-off is as you're
moving towards the right you're giving
up some control when you're running in a
managed environment you have to
understand the environment that you're
operating in and maybe change some your
application accordingly to take
advantage of that so even though being
staying on a more sort of for self
managed platforms gives you more freedom
moving towards the right side gives you
sort of more flexibility and and and you
know less overhead okay yeah that's a
lot about what containers are why you
should use them now to the true value
here how do we get there how do we go
from nothing to something in the world
of containerization now the key to this
is it doesn't have to be everything at
once right there's no there's no
sledgehammer that fixes this Warner
right we want to break down the problem
into different components and take off
tackle each one of those components one
at a time and so the first step today is
what have they got and what category
does it fall into inventory and classify
now inventory as I'm sure you know is
not straightforward in doing an infantry
of every application that you run or
your customer runs is very very
difficult so we're not necessarily
suggesting here that we want to spend
all of our time talking about inventory
every application right down to the tiny
little ones that are barely used and
hiding in the corners the real meat here
is in the classification so find the 80%
of the applications and then focusing on
those to see which ones of those we can
go we can use in which wave and we
basically said there are three groups
ranked Group one we're talking about
stateless applications things where we
don't care we don't need to remember
what happened last time around so
classic examples web front-ends some
some micro-services api's but anything
where the current request doesn't need
any context from the prior prior
requests these are great candidates for
containerization they should be once you
found this group this is the first group
this is the first movements this is the
thing that is the easiest to do and will
give you the most impact straightaway so
finding this category is the step is the
place where you want to be to move
quickly yeah the second group is what
we're calling the second movers these
are applications that have some state
but the state is temporary even if you
lose the state it's not a big deal like
caching is a great example of that when
you start a caching application it
doesn't have anything stored in it you
build up the cache as the application
runs and then it's it's useful that you
can look up that you know things that
are cached already but if it you know if
you had restarted yes you lose some you
know the the the the agility of being
able to look up things from the cache
but it's not the end of the world you
can restart and you know start over it's
it's an accelerator right they
accelerate performance but the actual
tainted loss is not critical yeah other
so other examples in this category would
be things that have like a master/slave
component sort of thing where one
instance is the master and there are
separate slave slaves so again each
instance is not the same there is some
state that is sort of unique to each
instance so those those kind of
applications are again a little bit
harder to contain not containerize but
run if
actively in a containerized environment
creating a container is not as difficult
that the challenge comes from actually
managing it in a containerized
environment running it in a container
isin oil and then this group 3 the
harder group the stateful applications
now you'll hear lots of people say don't
run stateful applications in containers
containerized environments it's a good
guidance it's not because you can't and
it's not because there's no there's no
value to doing so it's because it's hard
and the value is minimal compared to the
other things so anytime you find one of
these fateful applications that goes in
tier 3 because in wave 3 right now it
can be done some good example storage
databases right loot
container Eisinger my sequel database is
not necessarily the easiest thing in the
world it can be done but this work does
process and if you think about the
reasons for containerization talking
about ease of scaling the performance
savings things like that
a database doesn't lend itself as well
as easily to that as something like a
web front-end does
and again it's very possible it can be
done but it's definitely lower on the
list of priorities when it comes to
investing your your employees time and
your time in actually building and
changing that the application yep and if
you think about it you can't just
instantiate another database and expect
it to sort of work seamlessly there's a
lot of work that goes on to make the
replication and and other things work
across these kind of applications so the
benefits that you get from
containerization of ability to scale up
quickly and scale down based on demand
is is not easily sort of done with these
kind of applications so that's why we're
saying that this should be the newest
product at the end of the talk we'll
come back to some examples of where you
can see this done the right way that you
can go and look at if you if you do get
to that that stage 3 that grid 3 so yes
so that was the first part is to
inventory and sort of classify your
applications into different groups the
second part is how do you now start
container rising those applications so
we'll go through a number of examples
and you know the the the great thing is
that you know you could be anywhere
along this journey this is typically how
organizations start a lot of
might be running what are called
monolithic applications so you have one
sort of application that has the the
front-end and the services everything in
one runtime maybe like a java enterprise
application that does everything is an
example of that so those are typically
called monolithic applications and you
know you have a database where you store
some of the state and then the the the
monolith runs both your front end as
well as the as the application so you
can containerize it so the part to
containerize is that monolith and the
the positives of that are this is sort
of this proves the concept if you're
just starting on this journey it shows
you that you can containerize and
without investing a lot of effort in
reaaargh it acting you're you're proving
that you know you're getting familiar
with the containerized world and proving
that you you can you can manage it on
the other hand yes mentioned earlier you
now just have the same application that
is containerized it's running in a
container but it's pretty much exactly
the same so there's actually minimal
benefit to doing this the primary piece
is that it's like practice it's an easy
win right we can take one thing say oh
hey cool I know how to container as an
application and there's this learning
and merit in doing that in its in and of
itself but it doesn't really give you
the scalability like the chances of that
then becoming very scalable just by
putting it in a container is very slow
so you haven't got those full business
benefits we've been talking about but
you have proven hey I know how to do
this I know the technologies I know the
tools which gives you confidence or we
move on to the next time yeah so then
the next step along the journey and you
may already be here is as we mentioned
that you know you have to take out the
stateless portion of your application
and sort of container eyes so container
eyes them separately so what we're doing
is this is sort of a three-tier design
where you have a front-end separate from
your back-end and then you have the
database as well so this might be the
next logical step and in this you would
again do well to containerize the
front-end and the backend separately in
separate containers the the box is not
meant to show that you put them in the
same
container you put them in separate
containers but that's the portion of
your application that you you should
start looking at container izing and
again the positives are you can scale
the tiers individually if you have a lot
of front-end requests people are just
maybe browsing and not doing interacting
with with things that require back-end
services you can scale that up and down
independent of the services again the
drawback are that you know you're not
getting the full benefits this is still
not scalable but the great thing is
you're getting closer to the micro
services architecture which is you know
which is I guess everybody loves that
and wants to go there so the great thing
is that containerization sort of forces
you towards that architecture so this
going along this journey you'll end up
with a number of micro services along
the way and each of these application
architectures we're showing here and
moving increasingly away from the
monolith increasingly towards the micro
services model and the idea here is we
show each stage where we can imply the
containerization technology and how that
enables us to move further down that
path so it may be that you and your
customers have started off at the pure
monolith or or any one of these
architectures down the line which one I
say is there's a journey and a path
forward that you can enter in any of
those places so this is this is one the
three-tier and the next one would be if
you have a transitional microservices
architecture so it's like a traditional
three-tier application but now some of
those back-end pieces are broken house
their own service so in this particular
example service a may be its
authentication maybe it's the item
library catalog' whatever it might be
has already been broken off as its own
service it hasn't necessarily already
been containerized it may be just
running in a few more a few VMs or
something like that that is a great
candidate for containerization yeah
we're now we're now talking about the
ability to take that one service and
scale it up and scale it down very
easily move it across different
platforms reduce overhead increase
security etc etc and wisk we're creating
by doing this a pattern that we can then
use as we move further down the
micro-services path you can think of it
as a toe in the water of micro-services
architecture right you don't have to
touch the existing monolith that that
remains unchanged
so there's minimal risk in the
application so if this is this is a
business critical application that's
actually generating the revenue there's
minimal risk in doing these changes
however that's a good thing and a bad
thing right because now we still have
them on lift there's presumably a reason
why you want to move away from them on
lift whatever that reason is this
doesn't solve right it's a step in the
right direction but you're still left
with those with those problems that you
have before yep and the other other
great thing with this approach is that
now you're you're not really tackling
the whole thing at once your existing
applications continues to run and be
useful and you're transitioning slowly
to this new architecture so you have
fewer disruptions and and you're
learning as you're as you're getting
comfortable in this new architecture in
the containerized world you're learning
and and you know it's sort of spread out
over time so your risk is reduced as
well exactly I mean the next step
towards microservices you could add an
IP okay yeah and then what you can do is
one pattern that we see that is very
useful if you're going in this kind of a
journey is to add an API gateway API
gateway sort of hides the services that
are at the backend from your clients
which includes your front-end as well as
some some clients might directly be
connecting to your services like if you
have a mobile application that runs you
know that is not a browser-based it's a
native application it may need to call
services and if it goes through the API
gateway then it you know it can it
doesn't need to know exactly how the
services are laid out at the backend so
it has a number of advantages so that
might be the next logical step that you
introduce into your architecture add a
gateway which will hide the details of
the endpoints of actual services and as
you move them around it doesn't matter
whether you're the response is coming
from your monolith or just the new
service that you've added the the
clients don't have to know that detail
and that way you can easily change the
service endpoints you can you can
introduce a new service you can move it
around and so on and so forth the
drawback here is that you need to build
this sort of gateway
and and this is a common pattern though
that that we see in the industry so
there are a lot of examples out there
and and you know taking this step
shouldn't be daunting and it's not
wasted effort yeah right you're in the
dream state yeah fully microservices
architecture you may still want to have
the API gateway so this is not it's not
work you're gonna do it in throw away
its work which is useful later on yep
all right and then you know you can you
can build on that pattern and you can
scale out sort of your services you can
keep taking sort of services out of your
monolith and and keep putting them into
new sort of service-oriented
architecture and this is a an approach
that a lot of people recommend even if
you're starting with the new application
even if you're if you have a Greenfield
application there are two sort of
schools of thought in microservices some
people believe that you should you
shouldn't start with micro services you
should build them as you need them as
you as as your use cases are seen you
truly realize what services you need if
you sort of theoretically start with
some services that you think you might
need that may not be the right division
so this sort of allows you to to sort of
move into this micro services
architecture you know at at your own
pace and in the dream world this legacy
back in goes away right the dream
utopian future is everything's a micro
service I mean a full micro service like
a picture the reality in the field at
least that we're seeing is that doesn't
really work there's always some element
or usually some element that needs to
remain maybe it's some hardware that
doesn't you can't move to the cloud or
move to your micro services maybe
there's some legacy software which has
some licensing requirement that you
can't meet in the new world but what
we're talking is the nineteen ninety
five percent of the functionality of the
application moves into these micro
services now does anybody recognize this
pattern you know seen this before does
anyone know we're talking about shout
out shout out louder my turret my
hearings terrible yeah you seen this in
the Platina field I'm gonna go to my
plant who I know knows the answer
Strangler patent exactly so those of you
seen this before the principle goes
right if you have a great big tree right
that's been standing for a hundred years
and there's vines growing around it
right each one of these micro-services
is the vine eventually when the vines
are big enough and complex enough and
strong enough if the tree dies and rots
away the vines remain in its place
it's very nice analogy for this right we
build the micro services around the
monolith until we have replaced all of
its functionality or 95% of its
functionality at which point we can shut
it down turn it off or turn or turn the
vast majority of off and we're left with
this true micro-services architecture
and in our professional services group
in our application development specialty
group we we use this all the time this
is this is our I'll go to market so to
speak with our customers where we will
we will pitch this idea and follow it
through with them where we can actually
start to replace the giant monolith with
beautiful microservices architecture
built around containers with
containerization kubernetes gke in in
most cases well we can actually start to
remove and replace that monolith and
this gives you another sort of insight
into when you have these micro services
running sort of independently you can
choose different products to run them in
you might run your front-end in App
Engine for example and run your back-end
services in kubernetes engine you might
have some services deployed as cloud
functions so it gives you the ability to
sort of pick and choose the appropriate
technology to run your actual
application in so that's sort of another
exactly idea around that yeah and you
get all the all the benefits we talked
about in the micro services architecture
right scale different services implement
new services replace existing ones it
really gives you those three things we
talked about the beginning the
lightweight the fast and a portable
whilst they are they are elements of
containers they are what we're striving
for in a micro services architecture as
well the two things I often hear our
customers will say well micro services
and containers means the same thing it's
not the same but it's very closely
related right the two go together
hand-in-hand very nicely you can do one
without the other you could do
containers without micro services you
could do micro services without
containers but the two when they're done
together gives you the
most value yeah and I guess the third
step is to sort of you know reap the
benefits of this new state and you know
and and enjoy that I guess the
micro-services architecture so I
mentioned earlier the ice forgot towards
the end we would talk about some
examples of stateful applications
running in kubernetes we actually have a
whole bunch of other things so something
that we're seeing out in the world with
our customers and with our partners is
that there is a large requests and
desire to have example applications and
workshops to go with them so that a
customer or business can understand how
do I do X with GAE and when I say X I
mean different things so how do I run GK
in an application in GK in production
how do I handle networking in jjigae how
do I run stateful applications in GAE
and the more we've seen those questions
come out the more we've come to
understand that we needed something from
professional from the professional
services viewpoint in addition to
everything that we had so we came out
with project helmsman and I'm very
pleased to announce that today is the
first day that the project helmsman code
is released into public open source you
can all go check this out straight off
and we thought you go check it out right
now if you wanted to straight after the
talk you will be OC at this URL here the
idea is we've come up with code samples
and there's a few few folks here sitting
here in the room we've been very heavily
involved with this so thank you very
much to you all yeah we now have open
source proof of concepts for all those
things I just mentioned and more we have
matching presentations which are
available to Google partners today with
more to come but allow you to walk
through a one-day or half-day workshop
of any number of any one of these
particular things so if you or your
customer has a question how do I
actually use GK in production we have an
example and we have a workshop to work
through
there will be more watch this space we
are will be releasing more and iterating
on these as time goes on and but I hope
that this generates a great deal of
value for you and for your customers
that I label you to really start to use
gke in the way that we hope it can and
we've tried to take real-world scenarios
I know these are sort of samples and
exam
but we've tried to sort of route them in
reality in what actually the customers
need so we have also covered a lot of
hybrid scenarios where you might be
running still running some applications
on-premise outside of the cloud so you
know it covers a lot of different
scenarios so I hope you find it useful
yeah
[Music]